if you had to battle demon Kings
powerful Sorcerers and girthy body parts
what would you do you'll need to get
revenge on the royalty that did horrible
things to you and your family and they
will stop at nothing to kill anyone you
know I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the Geral Kingdom in redo of the
Healer this kid is going to have
horrible things done to him and then do
the same horrible things to everyone
else for revenge in a world full of
Heroes kind-hearted kiaro here has just
discovered that he has been chosen by
the universe to become a hero known as a
Healer he tells his steps sister an and
they celebrate what he thinks will
change his life he quickly gets
recruited by one of the Local Heroes and
ruler of the land princess Flair they
take him to where she lives Geral
Kingdom excited he assumes he'll finally
be able to save Humanity from the
horrors of this world but that was his
biggest and hardest mistake reaching the
kingdom he quickly finds out that
princess Flair her people fail to see
him as a useful member and don't even
think of him as a human even thinking
his powers as a glorified medic are
beneath them they soon take advantage of
him drug him up and make him heal them
nonstop but because of how his power
Works he is forced to inherit their pain
and suffering each time he uses it soon
driving him mad and Flare's whole Squad
blade and bullet mostly starts squeezing
him dry of all of his powers in the most
nasty of ways possible kiaro quickly
grows to hate flare and her people and
his body gains resistance to the drugs
because they constantly give it to him
again and again and again finally coming
back to his old senses he quietly begins
to wait for the perfect moment to take
them out but one day Flair's crazy
sister visiting norn figures out that
kiaro isn't as weak anymore and he's
pretending to be getting discovered he
looks in shock and horror but she agrees
not to tell anyone if he acts like her
good little boy for the night mm a few
months later Flair's team engages in a
battle with the Demon Lord but Flair and
her Heroes use up all their energy
fighting and yell for kiaro to heal them
quickly but he turns on them and finally
begins his plan for Revenge ignoring
their requests their pleas for help he
attacks the now weakened Demon Lord and
quickly defeats her but that's when he
realizes that the Demon Lord isn't as
evil as flare said she was and finds out
that she was trying to protect something
from getting harmed acquiring her
abilities in battle he also gains her
heart the philosopher stone suddenly
with all this power he becomes the most
powerful healer in the World princess
flare begs him to heal them now now that
he's finally not a push boy but then he
tells her that because of what she did
to him he will now use his new powers to
rewind time and to go back to when this
journey started to take advantage of her
and all of her team Flair screams in
horror as kiaro commits his spell going
back in time rewinding everything back
to four years into the past suddenly he
wakes up back in his bed in his hometown
but he has no memory of what just
happened he then starts hearing strange
voices in his head and head out to do
errands but the voices in his head start
getting louder and louder directing him
to this forest and that's when this lady
star Spirit bursts from the water
telling him he may ask her one wish and
he tells her that he wants to receive
the sight of the spirit that sees all
and for some reason she granted to him
granting him the power to see all things
in the universe which is very handy like
for example someone's power levels and
abilities AKA stats and acquiring this
new power he also regains his horrifying
memories of what he just went through
and realiz that he just reset his time
Loop and he gave himself a new mission
to get revenge and take out princess
Flair and her team in the most
horrifying way possible okay well it
might seem like we have the upper hand
the rules of time travel are too
complicated for mere mortals to pay
attention to but if I was Karu I would
bypass three major mathematical time
travel theories that would allow us to
take out the risk or reduce it to very
little now online criticism of what just
happened aside kiaro here we know has
the most insane opport opportunity to
prevent all of that from happening
to him again but because his plan
involves time travel it means that we
need to be careful that we carry out
plans due to tons of time traveling
rules and paradoxes here's why
technically time travel doesn't exist as
it violates the second law of
Thermodynamics which basically means you
cannot unscramble an egg order will
always return into chaos at some point
and this rule applies to literally
everything in the universe you can't fix
a broken mirror exactly how it was
before and you can't go back to looking
or feeling like you are 20 years ago
when you're 90 traveling into the past
means especially if you include the
biggest Paradox that prevents time
travel known as the grandfather Paradox
we changing stuff in the past could
prevent stuff like you from being born
AKA The Butterfly Effect and this would
prevent you from traveling to the past
in the first place however even if we
could some say it is possible this would
cause Us in the past to create a new
second timeline known as the Multiverse
Theory but this still wouldn't help us
anyways as events that didn't happen in
the original timeline would have
happened in this one and this makes
predicting the future in this timeline
possible so in order to help myself out
the most we're going to do one thing
that we can do to make sure our plan
works and doesn't violate any of the
most common time travel laws now listen
whatever plan I'm going to have if I was
him I would make sure that we don't pull
the trigger on killing any of the Jal
Kingdom's main bad guys a Savor bet
would it ask someone else to do the
killing of our targets since this is one
way to avoid the Paradox that would not
go against the theory of relativity we
won't be breaking any time travel rules
and still we'll get the job done a few
days later just like in the last time
Loop he soon gets chosen by the universe
to become a hero and knows that flare
has sensed this and will soon pay his
town of visit in preparation he quickly
starts eating poisonous fruits and
berries of all kinds and he builds up a
resistance to poison way faster in order
for what's about to happen next over the
next few days everything happens like it
did in the past he finally reaches Jal
Kingdom but this time kiaro starts
watching flare and his kind heart wants
to know if she really is evil in this
time loop as well because she hasn't
done anything wrong yet using his eye
Powers he knows he isn't powerful enough
to take his revenge anytime soon so he
decides to let history repeat itself for
a bit and goes through all the
horrifying things that he went through
all over again and one day he gets
called to heal one of the Kingdom's
Warriors this kind-hearted girl named
Kura realizing that this part of the
time Loop wasn't in the last one he
cautiously uses his powers on her
healing her entire arm from scratch and
he quickly pretends to pass out so no
one believes he's actually powerful
seeing this princess Flair approaches
him and gets pissed off she tells the
men to lock kiaro up and force him to
become a stronger healer even if it
harms or hurts him hearing this Karu
realizes that she is the same evil woman
in this time Loop like she was in in the
last one and that flips the switch then
he gets ready to start his plans to
destroy her over the next few days kiaro
continues to pretend to be a good little
boy and complains that healing people
affects his sanity doing exactly what he
did before getting drugged up and
imprisoned while hundreds of Heroes come
to steal his powers every every day in
the most horrifying anime way possible
but this time thanks to the powers of
the philosopher stone from the last time
Loop kiaro has a reverse Uno healing
spell on him and he secretly begins to
absorb their powers and become more and
more powerful each time he gets used 6
months later the resistance to his drug
finally wears off and he overhears from
the outside guards that the powerful
King of the land has left the kingdom to
go on tour using this chance he escapes
his cage and begins his plans a little
while later one of the soldiers named r
nard here captures Karu and tells
princess flare that he has some urgent
confidential news about kiaro that he
must discuss with her she tells him to
lock him up and come to her room walking
inside he quickly kills Flair's
bodyguards and uses a sword technique
and captures her revealing that he is
actually Karu in Disguise and that the
fake Karo she saw earlier was actually
Bernard with his enhanced Powers he
absorbs all of Flair's magic making her
helpless and she begs for her life but
he ignores it and proceeds to do all
sorts of the worst things that she did
to him and then some and after he's done
he uses magic to change everything about
her and erases her memory of who she was
renaming her Freya and with the kingdom
burning down he magically changes one of
the Dead bodyguards into Princess Flair
and quickly frames rard for the murder
of the royal princess taking her from
the castle the next day flare now Freya
wakes up with no memory of who she is
and kiaro implants more fake memories
into her saying that they are a couple
in love and that she lives to serve him
turning her into his little lap dog but
unfortunately with heat on his tail
kiaro soon decided to leave the kingdom
with Freya but soon over hears the
villagers talking about his real mortal
enemy Flair's sister norn she will soon
return to the capital and get to the
bottom of her sister's murder and Karu
realizes that taking her out one day
will be his biggest challenge a few days
later they arrive at the town of Larita
but kiaro notices that a disease has
started making everyone sick using his
eye Powers he discovers that the water
that everyone is drinking is poisonous
and that their water source was
contaminated by monster carcasses
needing more money for his revenge
Mission he comes up with a plan and
quickly makes a cure for the town's
sickness using his healing magic and his
blood soon he meets up with a merchant
and manages to cut a deal with him
delivering batches of medicine every few
days for a ton of cash under the table
of course all the while keeping his
identity a secret in this town but now
that he has extra funds with him he and
Freya head to the servant shop to pick
up a new addition seeing all of the
wonderful products he then changes his
mind and tells the shopkeeper he's
looking for a more durable item that
will suit his lifestyle for cheap and he
heads down into the storage basement and
he sees all the crappy additions and
they're not impressive and he spots this
low tech product named setsuna but
because of his eye Powers he can tell
that she is weak from the town's poison
water she's been drinking but has the
potential to become a lethal killer and
the perfect assassin he chats her up and
tells her that she has been betrayed by
someone who took her kind and made them
into servants and now she wants revenge
on him just like him so he buys her and
takes her home where he takes a closer
look into her memories and sees that she
wants revenge against the same Kingdom
that he escaped from Geral Kingdom KIRO
quickly takes a liking to ETS and thinks
that unlike Freya she is a good person
he then proposes to make a deal with her
saying that he'll make her stronger with
his insane Powers so she can take
revenge if she becomes his servant for
life and she accepts his deal he then
celebrates with her with a life
revitalization class to help her make
her stronger he then helps her get
revenge that night they track to where
the remaining members of her clan are
and comes across them battling soldiers
from the Geral Kingdom kiaro then puts
on a mask and pretends to be the famous
warrior he helped once before CA clarent
that announces to the ice wolf clan that
setsuna is alive and he's here to stop
the Kingdom from doing bad things and
they engage in warfare using freya's
magic the three go off and brutally take
out this party of human Soldiers with
these coding the dirty Battlefield
around them with blood he finally allows
setsa to try out her new power level and
she rips Claws and goes berserk on all
of these guys it's beautiful but kiaro
notices that Freya with her old memories
erased now has none of the evilness that
her old identity flare had and wonders
if draw Kingdom made her this way just
as him and the ice wolf Clan win the
battle my can and cannot trust okay
while this may look impressive how KIRO
did this whole thing was Dumb and he
just compromised his identity setsuna
here is the only one whose motives make
sense her people known as the ice wolf
for race basically got kicked out of
their lands and got turned into servants
and it makes sense why she would want to
destroy them however what they just did
now was dumb as hell and totally
unnecessary kiaro pretending to be
somebody from the Jal Kingdom means that
he essentially offered them more info to
figure out his true identity dressing up
as somebody from that kingdom was pretty
stupid as this would have allowed his
enemies to begin tracking down who Kua
knew and who she crossed paths with this
whole time and I don't want to even know
about how dumb it was to use cua's
special technique that only a few people
know how to use if I was him aside from
keeping a low profile during battle
instead of announcing anything I would
have used less impressive magical
displays and have charged in from the
front while directing Frey and cesa on
opposite ends hitting left and right
side of the armies in a sort of pins
movement taking the troops out without
too much much display of our powers
would have also made sure that no
eyewitness account would have been able
to tell what type of powers we used
during battle like honestly this is a
less is more situation don't give a
whole freaking Kingdom more information
on how to figure out who you are he was
thinking like a narcissistic peacock
wanting to show off instead of being
like an actual man with a plan meanwhile
back in Geral Kingdom Flair's far more
dangerous sister norn has finally
returned to investigate her sister's
murder but she doesn't believe Bernard
is the murderer and thinks it was
actually Karu she convinces the king to
give Bernard one more chance to prove
himself by going after and hunting down
Karu himself nearby one of the only good
Heroes around Kura overhears some people
talking about their army this man says
they were wiped out by someone using the
same sword technique as her which is
impossible back in karo's location him
and his team head back to the town they
are camping at and decide is time to
move out they head to the merchant
selling his potion to collect their
final payment but he screws them over
saying he wants the full recipe or else
still wanting to keep a low profile he
agrees to selling him the formula
writing down a fake recipe in exchange
for 500 gold coins as him and his team
get out of there but that's when he gets
attacked by Kura and kiaro almost isn't
prepared alert she tells him that she's
tracked him down to find out who he is
because only her family knows how to use
the sord technique that he's been using
he tells her he's a nobody but she
doesn't believe him and says he killed
her Men last night when they were just
trying to protect the ice wolf Village
but SSA here calls BS on that tells her
that her men were actually trying to
attack the village and turn her people
into servants kiaro actually saved them
could I doesn't believe a word she says
and attacks him using his magic eye he
spots cua's weakness and leaves an
opening in combat on purpose she spots
this and quickly Cuts karo's hand clean
off revealing her left side defenseless
kiaro quickly healing his arm takes
advantage and grabs her exposed face and
forces her to see all of the horrors her
kingdom has done and she passes out
later she wakes up and is shocked to
find out the truth they tell her that
ger all kingdom is in protecting
demihumans like setsuna but is actually
taking advantage of people like her and
kiaro finally reveals himself as the one
who healed her arm way back in the
kingdom when he was still a little boy
and he secretly tells Freya to pretend
to be princess Flair even though she is
but has no memory of it and he quickly
implants her with even more fake
memories and she enters and tells CA
that kiaro saved her life after they
tried to expose your all Kingdom Berard
found them out and imprisoned kiaro who
tried to silence her this is why she
faked her own death and left with him
and so by mixing a cocktail of lies and
some truth Freya does exactly as KIRO
wants it makes CUA think that they are
actually the good guys even though they
are and their also sort of evil and I'm
so here for it she's shocked and
convinced by Flair's surprise and she
agrees to join forces with him and even
agrees to be a part of karo's hero
roster if you know what I mean the next
day troops from Geral Kingdom finally
show up to this town and kiaro discovers
that they're holding people from his
village hostage they know that he's
behind this but kiaro realizes that
they're looking for his old identity and
means that he still has the element of
surprise okay now I don't know about you
all this may come across as a shock dra
all Kingdom suddenly springing under
kiaro with his villagers could have been
predicted if we looked at the past
events and it all started back when
kiaro messed up during that ice battle
scene not only did he give the enemy
more ways to identify himself but he
also failed to take into account the one
thing that was his biggest weakness his
family he rushed to save them he should
have just stayed low let his family die
because if he's truly all about revenge
he shouldn't have tried to save anybody
this was a moment of weakness he should
have been even more ruthless he should
just let those villagers die right now
because once the Geral Kingdom receives
word that he basically allowed all of
his family and his town to die they'd be
even more terrified of him they would
know that he wouldn't let nothing get in
his way of Revenge in short this kid
should have just committed to becoming a
full-on bad guy already because up until
now he's been only going halfway on
things and I hate quitters he quickly
sends Kura to find out more information
about the situation and she reports back
that the DW Kingdom attacked his town
because of him he decides to get more
information about himself and changes
his face into a stranger going out he
spots his beloved stepsister an and he
changes his identity into a draw Soldier
and spots where rard but finds out from
his memories that he found an and did
Despicable things to her against her
will Breaking Kiara's mind a little bit
more pissed off he changes back into his
old identity and kidnaps Renard and uses
his powers he turns Renard into a chick
and reveals to him that he's brainwashed
all of his troops nearby into forgetting
who they are and don't know that he is
Renard in a girl's body and he lets his
men have their way with him tracking and
down he soon finds her and rushes to her
Aid and tries to heal her with all his
powers but she dies in his arms and the
shock from this breaks karo's mind a
little more later he gets informed from
Korea that her kingdom is planning to
execute his Town's people at this
Stadium they're trying to lure him out
he gets a rundown of the area two
entryways heavy metal doors and two
specialized barriers designed to absorb
any magical powers or abilities within
the area it's a suicide mission but
kiaro doesn't care and the next day he
shows up ready to save people and
changes his identity back to his old
face unveiling himself to the world the
troops start killing the villagers but
kiaro doesn't stop approaching them
telling them that their deaths are on
their hands and the leader gets nervous
and the troops around him think kiaro
has officially gone mad desperate they
activate the defense barrier on the
stadium and think they've disabled
karo's power and the leader says that
they're all wearing crystals that keep
them from getting affected but that's
when all the troops around him start
collapsing and Karu smiles and reveals
that he knew about this and engineered
the barrier with his magic only to
affect anyone wearing the stone
necklaces that they're wearing quickly
taking it off the troops tell kiaro that
he's still trapped and outnumbered but
he tells them that he's a beast in a
cage and they are trapped with him
making these soldiers think that Karu
has officially lost his mind okay
everyone here is going to be totally
screwed and I love it kar's Insanity
though could be easily explained with
something that I like to call a
discontinuity Theory KIRO has I guess
you could say gone batshit crazy and the
thing is just about any person can slip
into madness and contract over 200 forms
of mental illness I know I have a few of
those however Carol acting like he did
do show signs that he has developed
bipolar disorder and while this disorder
is more commonly inherited it can be
acquired through other ways cuz as we've
clearly seen he's got that dog in him
and this illness you could say can cause
hypersexuality during a manic episode
because he can seemingly switch into a
psycho on the fit but due to seeing his
an die this deadly sent him over the
edge and officially broke him full-on
Insanity can be triggered by specific
events that cause someone extreme stress
cuz while things may seem tough now
kiaro started off as a naive kid wanting
to do good and had no idea about what
was really going on meaning his
foundational psyche was fragile and this
sudden shift in someone's psychological
profil can happen due to what is known
as discontinuity theory that is when
someone perceives a violation in some
domain of their life vital to their
sense of self-esteem like for example a
straight A student suddenly gets bad
grades and then he subconsciously
searches for ways to rationalize this
reason like for example developing
sexual or eating problems this is likely
what happened to Karu just now after the
traumatic experience he went through
plus the stress of committing Revenge
with no one else to talk to about it and
then finally seeing the only person he
knew and love die because of him it
makes him break down and shift into a
full-blown monster that's when he
notices the surviving villagers start
violently dying forcing him to realize
that they plan to Kill Them All Along
The Leader tells Karu that he knew
nothing about this part of the plan
making him realize that this was likely
all of gorn's evil plans about to fight
a giant hologram appears in the sky
around the stadium of Princess Flair the
citizen sees she's alive and she reveals
the war crimes that the Geral Kingdom
has committed and this is the reason
that she faked her own death in order
for Karu to help her to escape the
soldiers think she is an impostor but
then she starts singing using her powers
to activate level six magic fixed star
disabling the stadium Shield she puts on
an impressive display of magic proving
she is not an impostor and this
convinces the town's folk that them and
Karu are good and that J all kingdom is
bad they rise up and go against the
kingdom lighting the fuse on this
rebellion and everyone quickly starts
turning on these troops while Karu
escapes after he tells Kura that him and
his team are leaving the city but she
tells him to be careful because draal
kingdom is planning a widescale
expedition to the city of Veronica which
will happen soon making him realize that
in the first time Loop there was no
Expedition which means history is
changing and he now doesn't know what
the future will look like ca describes
to him that this new city is dangerous
and full of demons living with humans
but kiaro tells her that he wants to go
see a woman there who will soon become
the future Demon King the one from the
first time Loop curio wishes him good
luck and agrees to continue gathering
information for him while he prepares to
find his enemy blade and bullet on the
way to meet the future Demon King kiaro
then creates a makeshift staff to hold
freya's magic using a special Divine
ornament spell he wonders if he can get
a hold of a gemstone what kind of weapon
it will become the next day they reach
the city of Veronica and enter this Pub
full of drunks sitting down he bumps
into the Demon King who's younger and
looks different and Kiara realizes that
she isn't The Demon King yet but has
insane potential they Chad and he finds
out that she is from a race named the
Blackwing tribe and is just a low-level
demon these two drunk guys then chime in
and say that the current Demon King has
put a bounty on her people in order to
get rid of their race they warn kiaro
that as an outsider he should be careful
talking to her because if anyone from
The Demon King Squad shows up here she
is dead knowing he could use her for
part of his plan he warns her that she
must defend against an incoming attack
or else she'll die and that's when a
huge blast blows through the bar killing
these two drunk guys but KIRO notices
how easily this girl defended herself
while powerful he realizes that she
lacks experience and he quickly informs
her that based on the pattern attack
just now he thinks all of this was
planned and is actually a diversion she
tells him to leave her alone and that's
when she gets hit with a sleeping potion
now helpless kiaro tells her to hire him
to protect her if she promises to pay
him back when she moves up in the world
with nothing to lose or so she thinks
she accepts his deal unleashing the
powers of the world's greatest healer
quickly making more blood spill out and
through these Tavern Halls he then
rescues the future Demon King and they
all Escape later this girl wakes up and
Kiara Reveals His True goal he shows her
his special eye power and says they
already met in the future four years
from now when she becomes the Demon King
she thinks he's joking but then he
reveals that he is the hero of recovery
instantly alerting her and kiaro tells
her that he knows her real name is Eve
Reese of the Blackwing tribe using his
eye Powers he shows up that he knows her
full power stats and tells her that he
thinks her powers are necessary in order
for humans and demons to coexist in the
future and he wants to protect her until
she becomes the next Demon King because
she lacks in a bunch of skills right now
he tries to empathize with his future
victim and says he knows that most of
her tribe is dead and wants to help her
get revenge he wants the heart of the
current Demon King and can help her
train soon to fight him confused she
agrees to think about his offer later
kiaro tells her the full game plan to
improve her powers and to help her save
the remaining people of her tribe while
he gets the current Demon King's heart
and then she can finally end the war
between the demons and humans a war
created by the Geral Kingdom in order to
make a profit agreeing they begin their
training plan and then he finds out what
her powers are and what she can control
and he discovers that she has the
ability to control a Godlike creature
known as the Divine bird of fatal
diseases Karo basically drools at the
mouth and wants that power desperately
telling her that they should go see this
bird Now Eve War warns him it's
dangerous and says he must undertake
many trials but he tells her it's okay
because he's hot he then leaves the
girls behind changing his identity and
heads out later he spots a member of the
group that tried to kill Eve earlier but
quickly defeats him letting him go so he
can track his location later heading
back he informs the girls what just
happened and his new plan for them to
attack their Camp later tonight because
he needs to know how many more people
know Eve is here but wanting to have
some more fun before they attack the
girls take off their clothes and kiaro
joins in and Eve gets uncomfortable and
kiaro says she can step out for a moment
if she wants she runs out but still
hears the moans inside and starts to get
excited not knowing that all of this is
a part of karo's cheeky plans that night
sets attracts the demons to their camp
and kiaro sets up his plan taking this
liquid concentrate of aphrodisiac he
throws some of it on the Demon's
sleeping pet here waking it up as he
gets too excited and begins charging at
all the demons distracting them enough
so Karu and SSA can easily take them out
tying up these two survivors he
interrogates them and asks if their
group is the only one that knows about
Eve they claim they are but kiaro
doesn't trust them and leaves them down
here with this excited bull heading back
they change hotels to be safe but Eve
asks if she can stay in a separate room
kiaro tells her that they should all
stick together to be extra safe the next
day kiaro buys fre a step and fills it
with some of his magic but finds out
that its energy absorption is blocked he
fixes it and unlocks its full potential
the merchant here sees this and gets
impressed and Karu then makes a deal
with him fixing some of his other
weapons to get their weapons including a
mithil sword for free and that's when
they hear an announcement in the
distance and the town citizens wonder
what's going on concerned he tells Freo
to quickly head back up to the hotel
while he goes to check it out and that's
when he sees that his time is nearly up
nor entering the city with all of her
troops he scans their power levels and
knows that he won't be able to defeat
them easily and that's when he spots one
of his mortal enemies blade kiaro then
spots another enemy Hawkeye one of the
Braves and almost gets discovered by him
forcing him to leave and plan his attack
the next day he becomes friends with the
merchant from earlier and he makes a
business deal with him to sell him more
of his magic potions but he finds out
that last night he spotted blade doing
something horrible to one of the local
girls and warns him that they need to
watch themselves this gives kiaro a
messed up idea heading back he changes
his identity to a girl and asks these
two to dress him up giving himself a new
name Kiara preparing himself he did
heads down to the local bar that blade
was spotted at yesterday and waits for
her to arrive soon enough she enters and
spots Kiara approaching her blade tells
her that she's looking for a new girl
Kiara plays hard to get and says no but
blade plants a big fatty and transfers a
sleeping potion from her lips to Kiara
making her pass out going according to
plan blade takes her down this Alleyway
and that's when this stranger tries to
attack blade he claims he's the father
of the girl that that she did horrible
things to last night but Kiara
reflexively knocks him out and
accidentally reveals to bla that she
isn't an ordinary girl she takes out her
sacred sword and reveals how strong she
really is Kiara tries to hit her but
blade grabs her forcibly and knocks her
out a little later Kiara wakes up tied
and blade asks if she is an assassin and
randomly says she hates all men and
warns Kiara that she will destroy her as
punishment but quickly discovers that
Kiara is a dude by well you know how and
is shocked and she falls to the floor
and almost pukes saying she can't
believe she just touched the manly man
distracted Kiara uses this moment to to
break out of her rope and cuts her with
a poison blade slowing her down she
tries to reach for her Ragnarok blade
but gets pinned and kiar reveals that
she is Karu and says that blade just did
things to a dude and she freaks out
before passing out later she wakes up
and kiaro finds out from her that norin
is planning something evil with this
Village he realizes that she can't move
her legs and kiaro reveals some of her
men have been brainwashed into his
servants he says he would do the same
things she did to him saying these men
have now been possessed by hunger and
horny magic and they will try to eat her
unless she can satisfy them the other
way until morning if she manages to live
Kiara will set her free but she doesn't
and surprise dies in 10 seconds with her
death her hero weapon Ragnarok turns
into a plain gem with blade down kiaro
sets his sight on norn and eventually
bll it the next day kiaro pays a visit
to his friend Carmen but sees Hawkeye
also visiting trying to buy some potions
he can't tell who kiaro really is and
they make small talk with him leaving
and kiaro realizes that he'll have to
take him out first before he gets to
norn later kiaro converts the plain gem
he took from blade and turns it into his
new desired hero weapon wishing for
immortality he receives a new weapon the
sacred armor glove known as georgius
excited with his new power he gives
another life revitalization class to
most of his team the next day noren
announces to the citizens of Veronica
why they're really here they have come
to free the humans from the control of
the Demons the citizens get angry and
tell her that they were forced to make
peace with them years ago when ger all
Kingdom abandoned them getting pissed
off one human tries to attack norn but
gets killed by Hawkeye and norin then
uses this as an excuse and tells
everyone that the demons have now begun
brainwashing humans and it is up to them
to kill the demons and the brainwashed
humans okay well this situation looks
horrifying in reality the villagers
should have been able to escape all of
this and get everything they wanted if
they just targeted noren's feelings a
feeling less than her sister let me
explain norn here is the most sadistic
leader in the land and for good reasons
unlike like her younger sibling flare
she is what happens if someone grows up
in the shadow of their siblings because
of this she exhibits cold calculating
sadistic and merciless Tendencies
towards enemies and has no problem
playing dirty being even more sadistic
it was obvious that the protest Clash
that she just caused now was a classic
example of government instigation in a
way this is similar to the actual roles
that governments around the world have
been using for centuries known as a
agent provocator and using these agents
in order to manipulate crowds of people
and because of this if I was one of the
citizens I would have recognized this
from the start based on what norn was
saying a kingdom known for ruling over
people with an iron fist means that from
the Geto they were looking for an excuse
to use violence against this town to
prove a point and this should have been
expected even before the reason norn
gave to start killing off people known
that norn had a reputation for being a
psycho we should have reproached this
situation more calmly I would have begun
Distributing small slips of paper with
notes and instructions to everyone
telling the villagers reading it to
verbally say what was written on them
out loud like norin wasn't as talented
as her sister and norin doesn't have the
guts to let this town flourish in peace
unlike flare basically verbalizing to
noren that her sister is much more
talented it's noted that noren
overcompensates in her actions to make
people fear her by allowing the mob to
destroy her sense of self-identity and
shattering her ego through peaceful
means we would have been able to
convince her to leave us by embarrassing
her and causing her to leave without
giving her and her mental reason to
start fighting because it was obvious
from the get-go that they were there
looking to start something the soldiers
start slaughtering all of the innocent
citizens while kiaro watches in the
distance but then sees his new close
friend Carmen get killed as well pissed
off he activates his weapon and begin
slaughtering the bad guys with E and he
heads straight for norn and that's when
an image of a princess flare appears in
the sky and tells all the Dall soldiers
to stop fighting and leave the city
immediately this confuses Norton and
Hawkeye watching from their Castle
giving kiaro enough time to hawkey
reacts with superhuman speed and puts up
a good fight but kiaro easily defeats
him but is now overpowered Godlike
powers and at this point he's so strong
it doesn't even make sense he approaches
norin and she realizes who kiaro really
is a little later she wakes up tied up
and kiaro blames her for everything and
tells her he'll let her go free if she
wins this new game he brings in Flair
now hypnotized into a puppy and tells
her that if noren can resist not getting
excited by her sister until morning
he'll let her go but of course she loses
in 10 seconds and kiaro then erases her
memory and becomes his servant the next
day Kura pays him a visit saying she was
worried about him but he tells her that
all is good and introduces her to his
long lost family friend here who is
really nor he then puts a big fatty on
Kura and they all participate in another
life revitalization class while Eve
watches from the bleachers a little
while later kiaro tells everyone that
his closest enemies defeated their
missions is still not over they will now
head out to help Eve capture the Divine
bird of fatal diseases in order to stop
the current Demon King and in order for
kiaro to obtain the philosopher stone
and become the most powerful healer in
the world he then says goodbye to his
and second best friend Carmen from 6 fet
under meanwhile the ruler of the draw
Kingdom orders karo's mortal enemy
bullet to go and stop him making bullet
excited to finally meet his baby boy
again and Kiara realizes that he will
never get peace and no power or pleasure
he gets will ever make him truly happy
until he finally gets his revenge on
bullet someday because revenge is the
only thing in life that matters but what
do you guys think about the video don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
thumbs up down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist